150 ans après le moyen-âge en 1560 une
nouvelle campagne de grands travaux est
sur le point d'être lancé à chantilly à
la demande du nouveau maître des lieux
incertain Anne de moments
masculin c'est un peu déroutant pour
nous mais c'est bien un homme et cet
homme n'est pas n'importe qui c'est
l'une des personnes les plus puissantes
de France au 16e siècle il est connable
autrement dit le chef suprême des armées
et il est immensément riche un de
Montmorency était quand même
propriétaire de 600 fiefs et de 130
châteaux et seigneurie plus des hôtels
particuliers dans Paris et on sait qu'il
était très féru d’architecture et ce
personnage essentiel qui va avoir des
possessions dans toute la France va
faire de Chantilly ça principal
résidence et ça va être un tournant pour
l'histoire de Chantilly vraiment avec
des chantiers immenses qui vont être
menées des chantiers qui vont très vite
devenir un casse-tête pour les ouvriers
car après avoir ajouté des fenêtres à la
forteresse médiévale le commanditaire de
grandir pour recevoir les plus grands
rois de France et de Europe donc il faut
s'imaginer que la cour de France qui se
déploie c'est plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui bougent on trouve que le
château est un peu petit on veut
l'agrandir on est assez contraint par
les 7 tours et la forme triangulaire va
avoir sans arrêt à Chantilly le besoin
de trouver de l'espace et ce n'est pas
le seul problème que pose la forteresse
médiévale le connétable veut également
que son château respecte les codes
architecturaux de la Renaissance à
l'époque les nouvelles constructions
arborent une architecture parfaitement
symétrique comme ici à Chambord tout le
contraire de Chantilly donc c'est
vraiment une disposition qui a selon les
mots des hommes de la Renaissance une
sauvage cadrature donc il y a pas
d'angle droit c'est complètement bizarre
sur ce rocher il était très compliqué de
faire quoi que ce soit de symétrique
pour satisfaire les exigences du
commanditaire les ouvriers vont réaliser
un véritable tour de force il décide de
construire une extension sur l'eau un
petit château en avant de la forteresse
qui servira de hall d'entrée majestueux
pour les invités et pour réaliser cette
incroyable défi de construire sur l'eau
ils vont s'inspirer de la plus grande
ville flottante au monde donc ils ont
construit le petit château de la même
façon qui a été construit la ville de
Venise ils ont enfoncé des piliers en
bois dans la boue sous l'eau on va
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle parfois
des sonnettes ou des moutons qui sont
des sortes de grands poids on va faire
descendre régulièrement sur le pieu et
tant que le pieu descend on continue à
l'enfoncer une méthode qui nécessite
plusieurs précautions techniques sous
peine de voir la structure s'écrouler il
faut que les pilotises soient toujours
sous l'eau la règle d'or c'est celle là
parce que s'ils sont en dehors de l'eau
il y a une zone de contact et de
pourrissement qui peut se faire donc il
faut qu'il soit toujours noyé dans l'eau
et par dessus on fait ce qu'on appelle
un radius c'est un des poutres croisées
et on met des maçonneries qui vont
servir de support à la construction
elle-même
grâce à ce système de pilotis des
dizaines de mètres vont pouvoir être
gagnées sur